over the past four years again 2014 all
the way to 2017
huge amount of people in the us are
looking for
uh fantasy sports queries related
queries and in general sports stats
and you we didn't see it anywhere else
in the world so you ask yourself why so
many people looking for fantasy sports
what is it and that's how we started we
looked at an opportunity
and
we saw there is a huge gap between what
people are looking for and searching for
and what actually someone offered them
okay so we decided to
dig deep and and try to understand what
is fantasy support and what we can bring
to this domain
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders we are in
the sports world not in the field but in
the computer meet or lift shits the ceo
and founder of sidelines
or was drafted into the israeli air
force in 1999 and served as an f-16
fighter pilot for 10 years
he holds a bachelors of arts in
economics from the university of haifa
and an executive master of public
administration from nyu
upon completing his empa or joined
supersonic iron source to head their
east coast office he later on moved back
to israel to join google as an industry
manager
believing that upcoming changes in the
regulatory space around the us sports
industry will create massive business
opportunities or decided to start a
venture in this market and founded
fantasy advantage in 2017
or lyft welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today i'm so excited to have this
conversation with you thank you so much
for having me
we're going to have a great time i'm
going to be talking to you about
something that i know very very little
about but hopefully in this conversation
i'll know a little bit more about you
know the world of of sports betting but
not from the betting perspective but
from the digitalization perspective from
the data analytics perspective and you
know talking about scale when i think of
sports bidding i constantly go back to a
seinfeld episode where kramer goes and
bets on on a horse race and he's
standing there in the window flapping
with his with his dollar bills trying to
get into this deal
and i'm thinking okay how does this
actually happen you know in in between
2022 how does this happen online and
through data so or thank you so much for
coming here again it's a pleasure to
have to be here and hopefully i can
answer most of the question at least try
to
well we'll just have to get started and
see and and or tell me just a little bit
about yourself for context and and how
did you get even get into this world uh
great so my name is orr as as you said
i'm 40 years old live in tel aviv
originally born and raised in israel
spent some time in the us went to nyu
spent probably around six years in the
us so that's probably the first time i
heard about fantasy sports sports
betting american sport in general
so we spent a little time in the u.s
came back to israel worked for google
for for a few years almost four years
google in israel
mainly helping
israeli companies uh with all their
online acquisition efforts online
funnels online products uh across the
sea so again big israeli companies
they're trying to
capture the
opportunity around the world
and then back at the
i think it was around
2017 decided to leave google and go and
pursue a new opportunity
uh which i knew very little about uh
start when we started sports betting
fantasy sports and in general the
uh
the ability to help people get make
smarter decisions in a more easy fun way
around sports sports betting fantasy
sports or anything
related
take me 30 000 feet in the air the world
of sports betting what is it really
about what's happening what is the
sports betting
so
it's a great question and i think it's
really uh
it depends where in you're located
around the world so sports betting in
israel in europe in the us it's it's
very different and i think that's why
it's such a unique opportunity because
you know sports betting was around
for many years i think scenes started at
40 45 probably and if you go to europe
you'll see a very mature
uh
uh ecosystem with a lot of you know
operators that offer different
kind of sports betting and a lot of
other industry that just circling it
with you know with odds with line with
product with the engagement uh with the
offline and online connection so a very
mature industry but going to other
places around the world we started to
see a big shift or a huge difference so
but i have a question or is this more of
a cultural difference or is this more of
just the maturity of a market that is
destined to mature everywhere just not
yet in specific areas so i think in
general we see a sport consumption go up
okay so uh us is a great example so the
barrier is definitely not the conception
of sports people love sports in the us
but still there wasn't any sports
betting or anything similar until very
recently uh going back to europe you
understand that it's not about the
sports it's about the product about the
engagement and obviously regulation and
where more and more states decided to
change the view about sports betting
about fantasy sport you know you say
sports betting but it's a much
much larger industry uh we see a more uh
an increasing adoption rate and we see
that the shift from being something that
is small something that is borderline in
terms of the you know the the way the
the people view it
uh and and we see more and more states
and more and more countries around the
world understanding that it's just like
any other game and just entertainment
and again it's it's it's really depends
you know when you look at sports betting
it's a spectrum on on the far right side
there are people that look at it as if
it was stock trading okay so they do it
in a very
i would say sophisticated using stats
prediction
uh regression a lot of tools that we
know from
online trading
but that's such a small percentage of
the population
most you know most of us just love
sports want to watch it and want to add
some
skin to the game they want to earn their
bragging rights of you know telling
their friends look i know better than
you or this is my team
and obviously it's part of a game think
of it and that's the way the u.s
regulator look at it buying a ticket to
the
i don't know
to a and an experience to a game so you
pay 10 bucks you
put a put it on your team and suddenly
the game becomes much more interesting
interesting
digitalization of all this
and you know entering 2022 what are the
different opportunities that are
presented as we transition to digital
and a lot of these physical experiences
are now becoming more online experiences
so i think it's a great question and we
can see a great uh
example in the u.s market so let me just
give you like a brief brief uh history
about sports sports betting fantasies
and why
we enter this domain and i know very
very little about sports and sports
betting in general but we saw a huge
opportunity here so sports betting you
know it's part of sports for years
we saw states uh countries again we can
give europe as an example that that was
legalized and regulated for many years
and the market mature similar to other
products if you look at the i don't know
a
dating industry or a online delivery
industry or whatever so you saw that
sports betting picked up like any other
domain any other apps and we saw
products getting mature with the market
and then we have the u.s market that was
what we called not regulated it was it
was it it's not that it wasn't legal it
wasn't regulated so there wasn't any
local uh
supply or operators that that you know
launched product in the u.s market so
most of the people in the u.s just used
products from europe and it was again
very small percentage of the population
somewhere around 2018 the u.s supreme
court
decided to regulate sports betting in
the us they understood that instead of
having all the money go outside to
foreign countries and foreign states
mainly europe
they're going to regulate it in the us
and have local operators open
sportsbook mainly online and and then
they can also you know they can regulate
it and they can also enjoy of the
revenues that coming from taxes and and
whatnot
so it's a unique situation when a market
is open uh just
due to regulatory change in a day okay
so something that was
forbidden or illegal or unregulated
again depends on specific territory was
in uh
opened in a day
okay so it created a lot a lot of
opportunities and suddenly you needed to
come with products that were not existed
because again you saw other markets that
got mature with the products and they
needed to now come and launch it in in a
new new er
for new audiences in in the state so
that create a huge gap between where the
uh established big company were and what
the user are today so that gap offered
us to come and offer
uh
better tools better ways to explore it
better engagement and and i think most
most of all a better way to look at the
data analyze it and adopt it to
millennials to young people to people
that need to now begin their first uh
steps in this world
i love it and so we're obviously talking
a lot here about
you know changing consumer behavior and
and and i think that's fascinating what
is sidelines what is this company that
you're running and and how is it in line
with the new shifts of consumer behavior
that you were just talking about
okay so let's go back to 2017 when we
opened the company i think it would be
an interesting uh story and it can also
demonstrate how we look at the market
the opportunity and what we actually
offer today in the market so
i worked at google as i told you five
years ago
i decided that we're going to i'm going
to pursue it my next challenge looks for
the smartest person in the floor decided
to take him with me and look for
opportunities
um and when you work at google and you
know a lot about google internal
external
tools
there's a lot of a lot of data that you
can analyze and try to understand trends
user behaviors
um shifts in in you know in industries
and that's how we came across the
fantasy sport world you suddenly see
that
over the past four years again 2014 all
the way to 2017
huge amount of people in the us are
looking for
uh fantasy sports queries
related queries and in general sports
stats
and you we didn't see it anywhere else
in the world so you ask yourself why so
many people looking for fantasy sports
what is it
and that's how we started we looked at
an opportunity
and
we saw there is a huge gap between what
people are looking for and searching for
and what actually someone offered them
okay so we decided to
dig deep and and try to understand what
is fantasy support and what we can bring
to this domain
uh and that's how we started we saw that
that's sports and again sports stats
sports betting fantasy sports regardless
it's a very complicated domain where you
can go all the way from
uh you know trading tools
and on the right uh side of the spectrum
and all the way to you know just offer
very simple way to compare okay
and and we decided that we're going to
take this complex domain and try to make
it more simple
and more uh approachable to the average
fan so our audience is just me and you
and people that watch sports never bet
on sports and they said well this could
be fun let's try to do it in a more
simple
smart way and if i need to give you an
example think of
the shift that expedia did okay so what
they did they actually connected
themselves to all the relevant uh
airliners collect all the information
brought them to one place similar to
other
a grader and they started to play with
the data and drive conclusion build
products and now you can
uh book a flight in a very easy way the
cheapest one or the fastest route or
whatever someone's sells kosher food or
whatnot so this is what we did for the
online sport industry we built a huge
storage warehouse where we collect a lot
of different data points it can be lines
from different operators can be weather
it can be trends it can be injury feeds
what not again tons of data that come to
our system we process it and we try to
uh find trans insight and here it's
what's different with sidelines those
insights or those uh
key
uh prediction or whatnot we try to
package it in a way that will address or
will be relevant for the average joe
people that never played with odds and
that's most of our audience just
an average american that loves sports
so if you're not thinking about
this average person that you know that
is using that is using sidelines where
is really the aha moment because here
before
you were talking about this idea okay so
we have we're we're you know we're
comparing to expedia and we're saying
okay expedia took as an aggregator took
a lot of this information and allowed
people to buy cheaper quicker flights
but here you're actually referring to a
greater trend where there's a whole
generation of people who are not yet
exposed to fantasy sports and sports
betting and et cetera and now they're
able to do it because of the simplicity
of what you offer so is is the aha
moment more so
the fact that you're able to bring in
new audiences that previously were were
not a part of this ecosystem
or the fact that you're letting existing
traders or or existing bettors and and
people that are in this world already do
it just in a much smarter way so in in
general i think most american exposed to
sports and sports stats and they love
sport is something that is cross genders
across ages in the u.s so it's not uh
make it more you know it's not expose
them to the new domain you just look at
it from a different uh angle so for us
sports betting it's uh entertainment
okay that's how we see it we're not
addressing the people that want to do it
as a professional or you know people
that do it uh to to
earn money that's not the
the things that motivate our users
what we're trying to said aha moment we
have i think three aha moments or three
things that we identify as crucial to
our products
that are differentiate us from anyone
else in this market and build a huge
barrier modes and also allow us to
penetrate easily to the market and and
the first one is obviously the
experience people sometimes call it ui
and ux but it's more so it's building a
product that will give you a different
uh different experience uh it's not
about the bet okay placing a bet and
winning or losing no it's about the
overall experience so it's the
connection to media okay if i'm betting
on something there's a better chance
that i want to watch it and people
don't watch games they watch events they
watch highlights so it's a different way
to consume sports now you know again
millennials and gen z's are more into
heroes i like players i don't like teams
i don't know how old you are but i had a
team when i grew up most people today
they route for for players like i love
lebron
i don't care which team he's playing and
i want to see only his highlights and i
care only about his stats so this is the
first aha moment to just make something
different it's not about placing a bet
and see if i won or lose it's about the
way i consume media consume
my love to my um you know uh uh
heroes or
or in general how i want to watch the
game so that's the first aha moment the
second one is that the entire uh
engagement need to come with a very
robust
smart crm mechanism okay think of the
e-commerce you know when you go and shop
something and then they car you get a
i don't know an email that says listen
your cart is still it's not you still
have one item go which enterprise or
whatever there's so many things that
brands are communicating constantly with
you as a as a your zero with the online
buyer so we try to do the same with
sports betting or with again the
consumption of sports and sports stats
if you care about lebron and you place a
bet on what he's going to do tonight
we're going to be in constant
communication with you until the game
during the game and after the game so
we'll tell you a lebron is going to have
a killer knight tonight because we saw
that i don't know x y and z happen and
the game starts in two minutes and here
is the the first uh uh
three points that he just did or
whatever so we're going to have a
constant communication and the third aha
moment and again i know it's maybe
complicated but those three pillars
really uh make us different than what
any other product in the market today is
the social element again people don't
want to play them against the house they
don't want to gamble it's not about the
gambling it's not about the betting it's
about the overall experience i want that
my friends will see
that i uh
almost one or one or
not even close to winning whatever a
very complicated four way forward mean
different four different bets on
specific events and now i can share it
and people can also track it with me and
it's not about my 10 dollars become i
don't know whatever 100 it's the overall
process and discussion about it and the
bragging rights and the fact that
someone can come and say listen you know
nothing about sport and you can put it
in the office and again it's something
this is something that is very
cultural the element of you know playing
fantasy sport in the office and winning
and not losing and
and and i think that those three pillars
the experience the communication and the
social elements is something that no
other product in the market currently
offer
uh and maybe i'll just make an a very
important or crucial point we are not
what people call the house we are not
the bookie we are similar to expedia we
are not the airline so if we are not the
house and you're not playing a guest
house against us we are on your side
okay we want you to win we try to help
our winner uh user make smarter decision
so that's kind of a unique place to be
in
i think that's you know i was just
wondering about that because on one hand
you're you know a tech startup
talking about shifting consumer
behaviors talking about you know these
unique experiences talking about data
but then you know it's in the world of
betting and and obviously you know in
the tech world
there are some people that may try to
steer away from these things do you find
any
you know any feelings that as you go
about you know the day-to-day or the
growth of the company that there are
some people that that may not be
interested in what you're doing or maybe
a little bit taken back by simply the
industry that you're in or the fact that
you know it has any connotation to do
with gambling or betting definitely
definitely so you know it's a two-sided
sword so a lot of people would come and
try to come and work with us for us
alongside us because they love sports
it's a very
interesting domain and people love it
and you know
you'll come to our offices and you'll
see nfl games all over and we go watch
games and there is a huge sports
environment around it okay so this
from one hand on the other hand
obviously sports betting especially as
an israeli company here it's something
that is almost a taboo
uh i think that that's problem is mainly
here in in israel because in the us this
is such a
culture uh
it's so embedded in their culture since
college so it's much easier to operate
in the us especially now with the huge
change in regulation so
um
i don't see it different than any other
game you know eventually when you look
at the amounts you look at the
measurements that the regulator the
states and also the operators are doing
to make sure that that's still a safe
place
and not addicted again and it's really
it's a great question because we also
you know ask ourselves a lot of times
where we want to place ourselves
um
i think that you know personally i feel
comfortable and i think our investors
and especially now with the change in
regulation are much more uh
you know eager to go and hunt and go and
pursue this opportunity and obviously in
the us it's much easier it's never a
problem when you talk to a u.s
broadcaster employee or
someone that provides services they get
it immediately
oh thank you very very much for joining
me i learned a lot this was very
interesting
it's a world that i
know little about about it but i would
love to know much much more and then it
sounds like sidelines is a is a really
interesting company and it sounds like
you're so intentional about the way that
you're approaching you know your your
three big pillars of differentiation and
in what sounds like to be an emerging
market where consumer behavior is
rapidly shifting and and i'm excited to
see where where it takes sidelines and
where the world goes in general so thank
you very much for coming and sharing
with me thank you so much i appreciate
your time and the question and i hope
more and more people will come and work
with us for us and trying to capture the
opportunity because it's a huge huge one
that is just around the corner
you